On va parler à quelqu'un que
vous connaissez bien.
- Elles auraient bien voulu
s'y arrêter, mais ce sera
pour une autre fois.
- Je sais pas encore patiner,
mais j'aimerais vraiment
apprendre.
- Tu aurais aimé ça faire
du p
- Oui!
- Que ce soit à Montréal, Laval,
ou encore à Longueuil, presque
toutes les patinoires
extérieures sont fermées.
- C'est triste, mais on vit
avec la météo. Cette année c'est
moins bon, l'année passé c'était
génial. On va bien voir l'année
prochaine qu'est-ce que ça
donne.
- Pour ouvrir une patinoire
extérieure à Montréal,
il faut une accumulation
de 10 cm de neige au sol,
trois jours consécutifs avec
des températures sous les -5 °C
et aucune précipitation ne doit
tomber pendant ces journées.
Les seules patinoires
praticables en ce moment sont
réfrigérées, comme celle de
l'esplanade Tranquille dans
le Quartier des spectacles.
- C'est une des meilleures.
- Très le fun, ça fait longtemps
que je veux venir patiner.
- Je trouve que c'est bien de
patiner dehors dans le froid,
bien proececececec ses amis,
sa famille.
- Mais des patinoires
réfrigérées comme celle-là,
il n'y en a qu'une poignée
suelelelelelque 200 patinoires
extérieures de la Ville
de Montréal.
Et on en compte seulement une,
tant à Laval qu'à Longueuil.
- Il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui aimeraient patiner,
mais  qui n'ont
la possibilité, à cause...
disons, les patinoires à côté
près d'eux sont fermées.
Fait que senenenenenen viennent
ici ou quelque part d'autre,
mais genre, c'est dommage.
- Je trouve ça vraiment plate,qr
du bon temps dehors, il faut
qu'on soit dans les arénas,
puis que ça coûte de l'argenten.
- En effet, l'aréna est
la solution de rechange.
Il faut payer à certains
endroits, mais l'accès est
gratuit ailleurs, comme ici
à l'aréna Francis Bouillon
dans Hochelaga-Maisonneuve.
, , , , , , , employée,
Ville de Montréal
- On n'a pas de neige à
l'extérieur, fait qu'il y a
beaucoup, beaucoup plus de monde
qu'à la normale sur les glaces.
- Si certains apprécient
l'expérience...
- C'est parfait, des petitesrers
tempérées, on est bien, c'est
sécuritaire, fait qu'on est
vraiment contents.
- En fait, on est chanceuxd'd'ds
parce que justement les sports
d'hiver sont un peu limités à
Montréal.
- ...D'autres aimeraient
mieux patiner à l'extérieur.
- Je préfère être dehors, là,
respirer de l'air frais à
la place de l'air emmagasiné
là-dedans full CO2, là.
Moi, non merci.
- C'est pourri, on peut pas
jouer au hockey dehors, on ne
peut pas profiter des vacances
avec les enfants, fait qu'onicin
pareil.
- Et, il faudra encore
patienter. Selon la Ville,
les conditions météo neetetetete
des patinoires extérieures
d'ici la fin de la semaine